NEAL MUELLER: Hello, everyone,
and welcome to the third
in a series of three
on-air programs.
The first was about
getting started with GCP
and what you can build quickly.
The second was about
machine learning
and how you can inspire
love in your customers.
The third is about
bringing GCP close to you.
My name is Neal Mueller.
I work on the Geographic
Expansion team of GCP.
DAVE STIVER: Hi.
I'm Dave Stiver.
I'm a PM for our
geo-expansion efforts.
I've been at Google
for the last 12 years,
really building out the
compute storage and networking
infrastructure.
NEAL MUELLER: That's
a long time, Dave.
DAVE STIVER: Yeah.
It's part of what we really
use to bring GCP to you.
NEAL MUELLER: Great.
Let's get started.
We've got a bunch of content.
Before I get started,
I want to tell you
that you can leave
questions for us
anytime up until the
end of our presentation.
We're going to answer all your
questions at the very end.
We'll get to them
for sure, try to get
to every single one of them.
We're going to talk
for about 30 minutes,
and then we're going to answer
your questions for about 15.
OK.
DAVE STIVER: Great.
NEAL MUELLER: Let's get going.
DAVE STIVER: So just a
little bit of context.
Why are we doing this?
Why are we putting regions
all over the world?
There are really three
main requirements
that we look at for customers.
The number one reason
is performance.
They're looking for low
latency applications.
So we have to put our
infrastructure close to you
and close your customers.
The second reason is
high availability.
They want multiple locations to
select from in order for them
to meet their business
continuity needs
and build highly
available applications.
And then the last one
is really control.
We put these locations in
different parts of the world
because customers
really want control
over where they build
their applications
and where they store their data.
It's really important that
we bring the product to you.
And you, as customers,
get to pick where
you want your data to live.
NEAL MUELLER: OK.
DAVE STIVER: So if you look at
this infrastructure investment,
Google has really been a cloud
company for the last decade.
But if you think about
what cloud is doing even
at Google's scale, we
made a huge investment
in our infrastructure just
in the last three years.
If you look at just the
last three-year spend,
it's been over $30 billion,
which even at Google's scale
is a pretty large investment.
So this isn't something
small that we're doing.
It's something that's
fundamental to the company.
NEAL MUELLER: As
Eric Schmidt said
in our last Next in San
Francisco last summer,
we built a cloud this big
so that you don't have to.
To give you an idea about how
big our cloud looks physically,
let's bring ourselves
to the Netherlands.
So Dave and I just launched our
new region in the Netherlands
last month.
DAVE STIVER: Just a
couple of weeks ago.
NEAL MUELLER: Not long ago.
Although I didn't get a chance
to see this data center,
I had to share a couple
of the pictures with you.
To give you an idea, this is
our Netherlands data center,
which has a variety
of Google services--
Google search, YouTube, a
number of other services,
and then a GCP region
inside it as well.
You can see in the
distance some windmills
that are used to power this
region with renewable energy.
Security is something
we take very seriously.
This is what the exterior
security looks like.
As you can see, the
security guard shack
is covered with
grass, which I thought
was particularly beautiful.
On the inside, there
are different cells
of the data center which
separate different cells
from each other.
We operate the products
within Google very separately.
You can see we've got a mantrap
here with an IRA scanner
and a physical guard shack.
DAVE STIVER: Just one
note on that, I think,
to build on what
Neal said is it's
important to understand
we have data centers all
over the world, but we use
the same system of physical
and logical security
in order to make sure
that your data stays safe.
It looks a little bit different
at the data center level
wherever you go in the world,
but it's the same model
that we use everywhere.
NEAL MUELLER: Nice.
OK.
I mentioned something
about the environment
and how we use
renewable energy and how
we've reached 100%
renewable energy to power
our data centers globally.
Another thing that's
kind of interesting--
and I'll let you guys
in on a little secret--
is that when we first built this
data center a couple of years
ago, we discovered from
ecologists that we were
going to disrupt a bat habitat.
So our local cyber reliability
engineers and local officials
teamed up together to build this
thing that we call a bat cave.
This bat cave houses
a habitat of bats
that you can see in the
upper left-hand corner
of this picture.
They're about the
size of your finger.
And with the result
of this bat cave,
their habitat wasn't
disrupted, and we were
able to build this data center.
If the data center filling
up is any indication
of how much the bats are
going to start filling up,
we'll soon have to
build another bat cave.
DAVE STIVER: Yeah.
NEAL MUELLER: This is a
picture of a solar farm very
close to the Netherlands
data center that
produces enough solar energy
to power the Netherlands data
center.
You can see the windmills
in the distance too.
A note on energy.
Not only have we reached
100% renewable energy
by either consuming renewable
energy itself or by buying
enough offsets, but we also use
less energy in our data centers
than the industry average.
The industry average PUE, which
is a measure of effectiveness,
how much energy we're consuming
versus how much energy we're
wasting--
the industry average is 1.7.
Google's global average
across all of our data centers
is 1.12.
That's much, much less.
2 is bad, and 1 is really great.
1 means that every energy
that you're taking in,
you're using to power
the data center.
2 means that for every piece
of energy you're taking in,
you're wasting an
equivalent atom of energy
at the same time.
So we're 1.12, and the
industry average is 1.7.
This means that we can
build data centers like this
that operate at a
very high performance
but consume
appreciably less energy
than any other data
centers that we've
been able to find in the world.
DAVE STIVER: There's a
really interesting parallel
there, too, to draw between
the data center infrastructure
and the cloud world.
Things that are
important to Google
are being opened
with our technology.
And so when we were
doing all that work back
in 2008, 2009 in order to
improve our data center
efficiency, we got done
with all that work,
and then we published
all of that externally.
We shared it with the world.
We essentially wrote the
script or the playbook
for how other people could get
that kind of center efficiency.
So it's one of the proudest--
I was building data center
infrastructure at that time,
so it's really one of
the proudest moments
I had that we took
all of that IP
and made it publicly
available to everybody.
The corollary, really,
in the cloud world
is something like
Kubernetes, where
we take a really fundamental
core technology and then
open source it.
So open source is
super critical to us.
We're committed to
that as a company,
both at the data center
infrastructure level
and at the cloud level.
NEAL MUELLER: Wow.
Great.
DAVE STIVER: So if we think
a little bit about how
we layer cloud over the
top of all that data
center infrastructure, we can
talk a couple of dimensions.
And the first dimension is
probably cloud locations.
So we have multiple
versions of this
that you can think of to
choose from as a customer,
and we'll build
from the inside out.
So we'll start with zones.
You can think of zones as
independent failure domains
within a region.
So they're independent
across multiple dimensions
of the physical
infrastructure, so they
have isolation across
power, cooling, networking.
And probably most
importantly, the control plane
is isolated as well
in these zones.
So you can choose
these individually.
And then if you put a
couple of zones together--
usually we have three
zones per region.
You combine a couple of them
together, and you get a region.
So regions are a geographically
independent location.
So an example of one of our
oldest regions is in Iowa,
or we have one in
Belgium, or one that we
launched last year in Tokyo.
Those are all cloud regions
that customers can choose.
Then beyond that, if you combine
multiple regions together,
you get what's called
a multi-region.
And that's a product offering we
have where you can choose that.
And essentially, we
combine multiple regions
that are geographically
separate from one another
together into a
product offering that
gives you that level
of isolation and higher
availability.
And then the last one is global.
Global is a service that's
essentially spread everywhere
in the world where Google data
center infrastructure lives.
So that's something
where you don't even have
to think about the location.
It's just automatically spread
everywhere in the world.
And I think it's
worth maybe walking
through a couple of examples
of not just the locations,
but now how do the services
deploy on top of those.
Does that make sense?
NEAL MUELLER: Yeah.
Let's do it.
DAVE STIVER: Great.
So a couple of the product or
service deployment models--
I mentioned we have
regional offerings.
So something like Compute Engine
is a regional or zonal product.
You can choose a zone in
any region around the world.
Compute Engine is fundamental
to infrastructure GCP.
So you can pick in
Oregon or Northern
Virginia, all of our locations.
Another example is our Object
Storage product cloud storage.
It has both a regional and
a multi-regional offering.
So you can choose today
a bucket in the Americas
or in Europe or in Asia.
And when you upload
your data, we
will automatically
replicate that data
to those different regions for
that multi-regional offering
to give you the
higher availability.
And then the last
offering is global.
We have a product like
Pub/Sub, our messaging service,
which is inherently
everywhere in the world.
So that data and those
messages get spread everywhere
where we have infrastructure and
have Pub/Sub running depending
on where your customers are.
NEAL MUELLER: Good.
DAVE STIVER: Three
different offerings.
NEAL MUELLER: So let's
talk about a tool
that customers can use
if they've got questions.
DAVE STIVER: Yeah,
don't take it for me.
NEAL MUELLER: So we'll
leave the slides,
and we'll go to the
actual internet.
We're going to navigate
to a website that's
visible to all you guys.
It's cloud.google.com
/about/locations.
The top of the website
looks like this.
But if you scroll
down past the map,
you're going to see what
Dave and I call the matrix.
So let's walk them
through the matrix.
DAVE STIVER: So we have it
broken up by each market.
Today, it's the Americas,
it's Europe, and Asia-Pacific.
As we continue to
add regions, we'll
add more continents, probably.
But let's look at two services,
just so you can quickly
get an example.
Each column is a region, and
then each row is a service.
So Compute Engine,
as I mentioned,
is kind of a fundamental
core product in GCP.
Today, it's already available
in every single region in GCP.
And that's the goal.
That's where we want to
get, where as much of GCP
is available in
every single region
that we launched that
we have available today.
If you drop down
and look in Storage,
see something like
Cloud Bigtable.
Super popular product,
newer than Compute Engine.
It's actually trailing
a little bit behind.
We launch regions faster than
we can keep services growing.
But as you pace
through, if you look
through the different
markets, you
see that over the
course of this year,
Bigtable will start to show
up in more and more locations.
It's super important
that you know
that we're bringing
all of GCP to you
in each one of these locations.
So we're working through
our product list,
prioritizing and
regionalizing as much of GCP
as we can as quickly as
possible to make sure
that every region you pick is
a consistent user experience.
NEAL MUELLER: We do these
kind of presentations
in front of customers a lot.
And when we do them,
we invent words.
Supular is not my most
favorite invented word.
DAVE STIVER: Yeah.
We'll put that one in the book.
NEAL MUELLER: That's a good one.
We'll scroll down here
just so that folks can see.
As you can see, all of our
products are here listed.
And you can tell where they are
just by looking at the matrix.
OK.
Back to the slides.
DAVE STIVER: I'll let
you take this one.
NEAL MUELLER: Nice.
OK.
So we've talked
about the 15 regions
where we serve GCP customers.
You can think of these
into three big buckets--
Americas, Europe,
and Asia-Pacific.
On the x-axis here, we have
all of these 15 regions,
starting with Iowa and
ending all the way over here
with Sydney.
On the y-axis, we have how
much this costs for cores.
You could do this for
storage, or for big data,
or for machine
learning, or networking.
It would follow a very
similar trend line.
What you're seeing
here is that the cost
of providing GCP services
to you in the Americas
is a little bit less than in
Europe and a little bit less
in Asia-Pacific.
This is true across all
of the cloud providers
and also within Google.
Why is that, Dave?
DAVE STIVER: So part
of it is just the cost
of doing business varies.
The cost of energy is different
in each one of these locations,
and the cost of the land.
Part of it is the
age of the facility.
So there are
efficiencies that you
get the longer that
facility is up and running.
And the last one is
just economies of scale.
So you can see here if you
look, the oldest regions
are the largest regions.
And as we grow and get
more and more customers,
we get economies of scale.
And that allows
us to drop prices.
NEAL MUELLER: So what you can
see here is as a GCP customer,
you can pick wherever you
want to run workloads.
If you want the workload
to be very close to you,
you're going to benefit from the
speed of light benefits of it
being very nearby you.
If you're willing to let it
be a little bit further away,
you can go for--
you're now empowered
with the information
then to know where to buy that
for the least amount of money.
But I'd be remiss if I didn't
talk a bit about pricing
as compared to other
cloud providers
as long as we're
talking about us.
So we have a number of pricing
philosophies within GCP
that are very
advantageous to customers.
We call it
customer-friendly pricing.
One of them is called Sustained
Use Discounts, which I
abbreviated in this slide SUD.
Now, what sustained
use discount says
is if you're going to
use a piece of Compute
for 25% or more of the month,
you are granted a discount.
This is just automatic.
You don't have to apply
for it or send any emails,
make any phone calls.
You just get it on your bill.
If you use it for the
entirety of the month,
you can get up to
a 30% discount.
So think if you use it for 30
days, you get a 30% discount.
It's a nice, easy mnemonic.
So you can see our list
prices are listed here
in the height of the blue bar.
If you subtract
from that 30%, you
will see the SUD price,
the Sustained Use Discount.
Now, just as a
comparison, I've posted
what Amazon's price was
as of a couple of days
ago when I made this slide.
And you can see what
it is right here.
So you can see that
the general price
increases from America to Europe
and Asia is also with Amazon.
And in general, we
are much, much less.
When you account for
Sustained Use Discount,
we are appreciably less than
other public cloud providers,
including Amazon.
DAVE STIVER: So just to
give a little bit of context
to how we've grown, if you
look back, I think, 18 months,
we had four regions
around the world.
And today we have 15.
So that's, like, 300% growth
in the last 18 months,
which even at Google
scale is significant.
You can see all of
our launch regions
here in the map are in blue.
And then we have four new
regions that we've already
announced that are coming.
So Finland, Los
Angeles, Osaka, which
is our second region in Japan.
We just announced
that one, which
is important for DR in Japan.
And then Hong Kong--
they're all coming in 2018.
There are additional
regions coming as well.
We'll talk a little bit
about that later on.
But we have many
more in the pipeline.
This is just what
we've announced so far.
NEAL MUELLER: Nice.
The next website that
we'd like to show you
in addition to these
slides is like a tool
that you all can use.
It's called gcping.com.
Let me make this a little bit
bigger so you guys can read it.
So this is a website that
shows you which region might
be best for you.
Now, you might pick
best based on cost,
but you might pick
best based on speed.
And all the advancements that
Google does around our network,
we still can't adjust
the speed of light.
It is what it is.
And so the physically
closest region to you
is going to be the
fastest response time.
And this tool is a way for
you to figure that out.
So let's do a race.
Let's click here, and
we'll figure out which
is the closest region to us.
I'm guessing it's
going to be Oregon.
The one after that is going
to be Iowa, where I was born.
And then as we move
eastward, it'll
be to Northern Virginia
and then Montreal.
What's the farthest
region from us?
It's Mumbai, 304 milliseconds.
DAVE STIVER: Still not
bad, even though it's
on the other side of the world.
NEAL MUELLER: Yeah.
Interesting to note
that this test goes
over the public circuits.
If you are using Google's
private network, which we'll
tell you about in a
second, it would be less
than that, up to
half the latency,
so 150 milliseconds to Mumbai.
OK.
Back to the slides.
There, GCP.
DAVE STIVER: Yep.
Just to give you a little bit
of context visually for how we--
what this launch
velocity looks like,
one of the things that we
decided maybe two years ago
was we just weren't keeping pace
with the speed of our customers
and what they needed for us.
So we spent almost
a year, really,
building out a set
of automation tools
to allow us to quickly
turn up a new region.
So everything in our
stack, from the lowest
level of infrastructure--
every DIM,
every server, every
rack all the way up
to the top of the stack, our
managed services offering,
have all been automated
so that we can stand up
a set of new zones and
a region in a relatively
short amount of time.
So you can see what our
launch velocity look
like there in 2015 and 2016,
what we've been up to in 2017,
and then what we have
in store in 2018.
NEAL MUELLER: So
your automation is
why you were able to tumble
them out so quick in 2017?
DAVE STIVER: Yeah.
Without that, we never would
have been able to do this.
We'd be talking about 7 or
8 or 10 regions, not 15.
NEAL MUELLER: And from
what I'm hearing from you,
it's probably going
to just continue.
DAVE STIVER: Correct.
NEAL MUELLER: OK, good.
DAVE STIVER: Yeah.
For each one of those new
region launches, as I mentioned,
we're trying to put every
service in all locations.
But right now, this is the
standard offering that we have.
And it cuts across all
of the dimensions of GCP,
whether it's compute,
storage, big data, networking,
or IAAM services.
It's something that we
put into every location.
I did highlight a few
services because we just
finished the work on those.
Cloud Spanner and
Cloud Bigtable will now
be a part of every new
region launch going forward,
so you won't have
to wait for that.
Cloud BigQuery has
extensive plans
to roll out to more
locations in 2018,
and we'll get them
caught up shortly.
So that critical key feature
of GCP Cloud BigQuery
will be available
everywhere for you.
NEAL MUELLER: You're going
to put Spanner, Bigtable,
and BigQuery in every
single new region?
DAVE STIVER: That's what
we said 18 months ago.
How would we possibly do that?
Automation is the
way that we get that.
NEAL MUELLER: So we can expect
Hong Kong, Osaka, Finland, LA.
All of them will have those
three that you bolded there?
DAVE STIVER: Absolutely.
NEAL MUELLER: Fantastic.
DAVE STIVER: You
want me to take this?
NEAL MUELLER: You can start.
I'll finish.
DAVE STIVER: OK.
So we talk a lot about regions.
We talk a lot about services.
But one of the things that
we don't, sometimes, I think,
talk about enough
is the investment
that we've made in our
network infrastructure.
We've been building
out this global network
for over the last
15 years, really.
And it's kind of the
secret sauce of Google.
We have an expression a decade
ago almost now that said,
it's all about the network.
And it really is.
It's the tie that binds.
So you take this network
infrastructure investment,
combine it with all
the regions, combine it
with the edge caches and the
points of presence as we have,
and it really becomes
this global scale computer
that you can program on top of.
It's what all of our
engineers here at Google
program on top of it.
It's what they've
become accustomed to.
Be careful.
Once you get used to
how fast it is-- you
talked about how much
better the latency is.
Be careful.
Once you get used
to how fast it is,
it's hard to go back
to the public internet.
But this is really a significant
part of that infrastructure
investment.
NEAL MUELLER: The
only thing I would add
is if you've ever
used Google.com
and the brilliance
of search, you
have experienced this network.
It's the distributed
computing problem
that Google solved long
before I joined Google.
It was solved with
a network like this.
And it'll empower
your business to solve
incredibly delightful and joyous
user experiences like we've
done with google.com.
DAVE STIVER: OK.
What's the expression?
The expression is
politics is local.
So all politics is local.
All energy is local.
I like to say that.
All cloud is really local too.
So these regions
launches are not
just about putting
data centers in places.
They're really about us bringing
GCP and meeting customers
where they're at.
So we've been out launching
these regions for the last 18
months, going to
different locations.
And it's more than
just a data center.
It's a lot more than
that in terms of opening
p a new market.
NEAL MUELLER: Yeah.
It's about helping
local customers
with local salespeople and
local tech support people
and engaging local engineers.
Because Google has engineers
all over the world.
To give you a flavor
for this, we've
got two animated
GIFs and one photo.
So let's just start with
the one on the left.
OK.
So the one on the left is
about our German region
launch, which happened
right around Oktoberfest
of last year.
It was incredible.
On the left in that
picture, you see
Urs Holzle, who is Google's
first vice president.
He's been at Google
a long time--
16, 18, years, long time.
He's heavily engaged with the
geographic expansion of GCP.
On his left is
Michael Korbacher,
who's in charge of the customer
team in Germany and Austria
and Switzerland.
And they're pressing
a buzzer in front
of an audience of 300 customers
as they opened the first region
in Germany.
It was really exciting.
In the middle, we've got
someone that I recognize.
Dave Stiver is there
pressing the button
with our head of European
customer team, PH.
So he and PH are opening
up the first region
in the Netherlands.
That was just a
couple of weeks ago.
On the right-hand side
is really what we want
to do for every region launch.
On the right side
of the picture,
you see two members of
our product team, Maya
and Miles Ward.
To Miles's right,
you see Chris Klayko,
who is in charge of North
American customer team.
In the middle, you have
the mayor of Montreal,
because building
regions has a lot
to do with the entire
region, not just about
the data center that's there.
To the mayor's right, we've got
two of our bigger customers.
And then to their right
is our country head
of Canada for Google Cloud.
So we take opening up these
new regions very seriously.
It's more than just
a rack of compute.
It's about rooms and room and
room of people that are there
to help you with your problems,
to help sell you Cloud,
and to help you
solve your problems.
DAVE STIVER: I don't want to
set the wrong expectation.
But just in 2017, we launched
almost one region a month,
10 new regions in 2017.
We didn't quite get to one a
month, but we almost got there.
So far in 2018, we're almost
already doing two a month.
The Netherlands and
Montreal launched
within a day of one another.
So we're setting
a high bar already
in the first month of 2018.
I don't know if we can
keep up, but we'll try.
NEAL MUELLER: It's
fun to work on.
DAVE STIVER: Yeah.
NEAL MUELLER: Let's
talk about where
we're going to build next.
DAVE STIVER: Yeah.
I mentioned this at the
beginning of the discussion.
We're not done yet.
We're thinking about
lots of locations.
If you look at a
map of the world,
which I stare at all the time--
I spend 50% of my
time, really, talking
to customers in different
parts of the world,
trying to figure out what they
need, and then the other 50%
figuring out how
do we do the launch
in this particular location.
So we would love
to hear from you.
Here are some spots
that we're already in
and then some spots that
we're thinking about landing.
You can expect to see
additional locations
and markets we've
already gone to, like we
launched Osaka in Japan.
NEAL MUELLER: So Alaska, Hawaii.
That's just because we
highlighted America, right?
DAVE STIVER: Correct.
NEAL MUELLER: Got it.
DAVE STIVER: And with
the Montreal launch,
we now have Canada.
But there are other parts of
the world that still need GCP.
And so my ask to you is
take a look at that link.
NEAL MUELLER: Bit.ly/gcpregions.
It's a Google form
that you can fill out,
and it comes right
to Dave and I.
And you can tell
us what you think.
DAVE STIVER: Yeah.
Tell us where you want
us to go, and tell us
what we should bring
when we get there.
NEAL MUELLER: Oh, yeah.
So where do we want
to open a region?
Where do they want us to open
a region, and what services
do they want us to
put there, knowing
that Spanner and Bigtable
and the other one
is going to all be there.
DAVE STIVER: BigQuery
already coming.
But there are a lot
of services in GCP.
It's a big stack.
So I could always use help
from folks prioritizing
what should come next.
NEAL MUELLER: OK.
That is the last slide.
We are now ready to
answer questions.
DAVE STIVER: Perfect.
NEAL MUELLER: Stay
tuned for the live Q&A.
It will begin in
about one minute.
DAVE STIVER: OK.
We've got our questions.
You want me to dive in first?
NEAL MUELLER: How about I
read them, and you answer?
DAVE STIVER: Even better.
NEAL MUELLER: Questions
from the audience.
Thank you so much for
leaving questions.
If you don't see your
question answered by us now,
you can go ahead and tweet
either one of us on Twitter,
or you can go and fill out
that bit.ly/gcpregions.
There's probably a thing at the
bottom that says leave a note.
That note will come
directly to us,
so easy to get a hold of us.
OK.
First question.
How many total regions are
you planning on building?
DAVE STIVER: 32.
NEAL MUELLER: 42 is
the answer, right?
"Hitchhiker's Guide
to the Galaxy."
DAVE STIVER: Yes.
The actual-- I get
this question a lot
even internally at Google.
When do we stop?
The answer is when
customers really
stop asking us for new regions.
We look-- and this is combined
with that second question
as well, is how do you choose
where to build regions.
So it's all based
on customer demand.
We look at the attributes
that customers want from us,
whether it's
latency, whether it's
where they can store their
data, how many locations
do they need to meet their
availability guidelines, which
varies by industry.
We have a lot of customers
that we've already
on-boarded onto
cloud, but we know
it's not an easy journey,
particularly if you're
in an industry that has a lot
of regulatory requirements
that you need to work around.
That's why we're bringing these
regions to you-- to meet you
where you're at geographically,
and also in the state
that you're in.
And so to answer
the first question,
we don't have a number.
We'll build until
customers tell us to stop.
NEAL MUELLER: Nice.
That's good.
DAVE STIVER: Yeah.
If we're putting
numbers on, I think
we'll build less than 100.
NEAL MUELLER: Yeah.
That makes sense.
We have 100 points of
presence around the world.
So in the expanse of time, we
could imagine having a region
on top of each one of those.
But I imagine over
time, those get
re-shifted around as
customers demand them
in different locations.
So yeah.
DAVE STIVER: And the
definition of locations
will also continue to
grow as well, I think.
We'll get closer and
closer to customers.
As we've discovered how
important latency is in a lot
of the applications
that we build,
I think the market will start
to understand and have a better
appreciation for how
important that is,
and be able to pick what parts
of their applications need
to be super close to customers
and which ones don't.
NEAL MUELLER: The definition
of region might change too.
DAVE STIVER: Absolutely.
NEAL MUELLER: It might get
closer and closer to customers.
DAVE STIVER: Yep.
NEAL MUELLER: OK.
Question number 2.
How do you choose
where to build regions?
DAVE STIVER: That one I covered.
We pick it all based
on customer demand.
So it's constantly out
talking to the market,
figuring out what
they need, then
prioritizing, really, based
on the needs of our customers.
We have a huge customer
base all over the world.
A lot of our customers
are global enterprises.
So we find their needs are
expansive all over the world.
So they're looking for us to do
that work, all the data center
work, in order to give them
that single GCP API everywhere.
NEAL MUELLER: So I guess the
answer to that question is
bit.ly/gcpregions.
Fill out the form,
Dave and I find out.
Question number 3-- what changed
in your building strategy
to enable you to
launch regions faster?
Automation.
DAVE STIVER: Yeah,
that's a great question.
Automation is the first part.
NEAL MUELLER: Can you
dig in to one element
that I might not have expected
is included within automation?
DAVE STIVER: Yeah.
There are actually two
answers to this question.
The first part is automation,
so getting repeatability.
So we want to stamp these things
out and get the same footprint
everywhere so that
we're not re-engineering
in our architecture.
So we use the same
architecture everywhere.
That's key.
NEAL MUELLER: Homogeneity.
DAVE STIVER: Yep.
The second piece is we actually
had to change the way we did
data center infrastructure
because we have several huge,
one-billion-customer
applications inside of Google--
search, ads, Gmail.
These are huge services
inside of Google
that are all cloud customers.
They're all built on Google's
data center infrastructure.
Not every customer that we have
in public cloud is that size.
So we had to really look at
how do we tailor Google down
to the needs of our customers
and really shrink it
so we could quickly
bring the technologies
that they were
interested in to market
and then build out gradually.
And that's one of the
key differences as well.
If we had to bring all
of Google, every part--
if you need to run
search to a region--
NEAL MUELLER: Every
service, for example.
DAVE STIVER: Yes.
It would take much
longer to do this.
So we really pared that
down and developed something
that was specific to cloud.
It doesn't forget any of
the pieces that GCP needs,
but it was tailored
uniquely for cloud.
It's a kind of investment
in something specific
to a particular PA in Google
that I haven't seen before.
NEAL MUELLER: And that's maybe
why every region to begin with
doesn't have every
single service.
We're catering to the customers
that have demanded which
services, which is why it's
so important that customers go
to bit.ly/gcpregions and
tell us what they want.
DAVE STIVER: Please.
NEAL MUELLER: Number 4--
is there an equivalent to GCping
for competitors' data centers?
Yeah.
There's one for Azure.
But I don't know that
there's one for Amazon.
I also haven't seen one for
any of the other public clouds.
If you find me on Twitter
and ask me this question,
I will try to find
out your answer.
I think it's an
interesting question.
I would love to
see one that showed
all of the public clouds.
Here's why that
would be interesting.
That would be interesting
because you'll be able to see,
at your spot in my home
state of Minnesota,
which is the closest cloud
region to me physically.
That might be interesting.
It wouldn't be
interesting because it
wouldn't take account of
going over private networks.
For example, if you were
using our private network,
GCP is the largest private
network in the world.
You have access to it
every time you use GCP.
You don't have access to
it if you're not using GCP.
And so not always does
proximity in terms
of pings over public
transport equate
to alacrity of actual
experience with cloud.
See what I mean?
It's more complicated.
You might want to
actually boot up
a workload in each
of those clouds,
and then do it, and
then go over the-- it
would be more complicated.
Yeah, tweet me.
I'll find you an answer.
Number 5-- what are the
metrics or features that
determine a region, and
who are the people that
are involved in this process?
DAVE STIVER: Yeah.
I guess if you
think about what it
is we use to decide whether we
go-- what triggers, I think,
is the question here, what
triggers a new region.
For us, it's about
product market fit.
So I have a product that I
can take to market today.
I have a new region and
that set of products
that I'm launching with today.
And we make a minimum
infrastructure investment,
so we have to see
that there's demand
in the market for that
kind of investment.
And so we bring
together our sales team
that's out working
with customers
to assess their demand in that
location for new customers.
We're talking a lot to
our existing customers,
these global multinationals
who are looking
to spread their infrastructure
or their applications
around the world.
And then we have all the
internal stakeholders.
We actually have a number of
internal services at Google
who want to get to
these new regions
as quickly as they can as well.
So we balance the needs of
all of those stakeholders.
It's not just our
public customers,
but there are a
lot of internal--
I get emails every day
from Google engineers
in different services who want
access to these new regions.
NEAL MUELLER: Because
they want to use
Compute or Storage or
BigTable or Spanner
that is available publicly
to everybody else,
but they want to use it for
some of our internal products.
DAVE STIVER: Correct.
Correct.
NEAL MUELLER: Wow.
That's great.
DAVE STIVER: Yeah.
NEAL MUELLER: G on G.
DAVE STIVER: Yes, G on G.
NEAL MUELLER: Nice.
Those are the five questions.
Thank you all so
much for the time.
This was the third
of three webinars.
We do these webinars
every single Tuesday,
and they keep getting bigger
and better and more interesting.
So tune in next
Tuesday, and learn
more about what's
hot and new on GCP.
Thanks a lot.
DAVE STIVER: Awesome.
Thanks, Neal.
See you at the
next region launch.
NEAL MUELLER: See you at
the next region launch.
See you, Dave.